[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages
heute mit
guten abend und willkommen zum
nachrichtenüberblick an diesem montag
die vom sport hat norbert lehmann einen
schönen guten antrag von mir wir haben
unter anderem diese themen für sie
soviel treibhausgas wie nie die co2
konzentration in der atmosphäre ist im
corona jahr 2020 auf neue höchstwerte
gestiegen
full house im neuen bundestag vor der
ersten sitzung morgen gibt es gerangel
um die sitzordnung und um das neue
präsidium
aufruf zu mehr impft gerechtigkeit auf
dem weltgesundheitsgipfel in berlin
fordert der un-generalsekretär den
corona impfstoff sinnvoller zu verteilen
nur wenige tage vor dem klimagipfel in
glasgow zieht die weltwetterorganisation
wmo eine zutiefst ernüchternde bilanz
die klimaschädlichen treibhausgase in
der atmosphäre haben einen neuen
höchstwert erreicht trotz corona das
habe gravierende auswirkungen auf unser
leben unseren planeten und die zukunft
unsere kinder
beispiel co2 das wird für zwei drittel
der erderwärmung verantwortlich gemacht
obwohl die wirtschaft im ersten quartal
weitgehend stillstand stieg die
konzentration stärker als im schnitt der
letzten zehn jahre christoph distel
berichtet
madagaskar die insel vor der ostküste
afrikas hier heizt sich die erde noch
schneller auf als anderswo seit jahren
hat es nicht mehr richtig geregnet
millionen menschen leiden hunger viele
sterben infolge einer krise die nicht
sie sondern die industriestaaten
verschuldet haben doch die können sich
zum umsteuern kaum durchringen
australien etwa einer der weltgrößten
kohleproduzenten bleibt bei alten
emissionszielen brasilien und russland
haben eigene vorgaben sogar noch
abgeschwächt und auch china kanada die
usa und die eu hinken ihren versprechen
hinterher ergebnis die konzentration von
co2 in der atmosphäre ist nicht
niedriger sondern trotz corona
konjunkturdelle deutlich höher das
meldet die wm fast etwas ratlos
derzeit steuern wir eher auf eine
erderwärmung von zweieinhalb bis drei
grad zu als auf die anvisierten
anderthalb schon jetzt liegt die
weltweite erderwärmung bei
durchschnittlich 1,1 grad in deutschland
sogar noch höher bei 1,6 grad
klimaforscher drängen auf eine wende
also wir haben ja seit jahrzehnten
überhaupt kein erkenntnisproblem mehr
sondern wir haben ein umsetzungsproblem
und man muss es so deutlich sagen es
fehlt der politische wille beim
klimaschutz wirklich ein zu machen am
sonntag beginnt im schottischen glasgow
der nächste klimagipfel mit vielen
versprechungen der länder aber all das
eingerechnet gehen forscher trotzdem auf
jahre von weiter steigenden co2 werten
aus mit dramatischen folgen für die welt
von hochwasser bis dürre konkret heißt
das menschen werden vor dem extrem wird
er fliehen müssen länder um ressourcen
kämpfen und es wird rauer werden bei
ihrem streit um die richtigen maßnahmen
der kampf gegen die erderwärmung wird
auch für die künftige bundesregierung
eine der größten herausforderungen noch
stecken spd grüne und fdp in
koalitionsverhandlungen
trotzdem tritt morgen wie vom
grundgesetz vorgegebenen 30 tage nach
der wahl schon mal der neue bundestag
zusammen gerangel gibt es um die
sitzordnung und um das präsidium aus
berlin britta buchholz es wird der tag
der großen abschiede die regierungsbank
bleibt morgen leer die bundesregierung
rund um kanzlerin merkel nimmt auf der
tribüne platz angela merkel selbst
beendet neben der kanzlerschaft nach 31
jahren ihre zeit als abgeordnete
wolfgang schäuble ist schon seit 49
jahren dabei doch nun muss er das amt
des bundestagspräsidenten abgeben
nachfolgen wird ihm wohl bärbel bas die
spd politikerin stellte sich heute den
fraktionen vor gerangel um die vize die
cdu schickt yvonne mark was ins rennen
die afg stellt michael kaufmann zur wahl
auch wenn die partei schon sechsmal mit
ihrem kandidaten gescheitert ist ich
hoffe einfach dass jetzt viele
abgeordnete sich doch auf einen
demokratischen stil besinnen und von
ausgrenzung und spaltung ab wir meinen
diensten oder demokratie jetzt
alle vier präsidenten zu wählen die spd
bleibt aber skeptisch gegenüber dem afd
kandidaten jeder abgeordnete meiner
fraktion ist bei der abstimmung frei
muss aber gleichzeitig darauf hinweisen
dass die afg sich weiterhin zusätzlich
radikalisierter gerangel auch bei der
sitzordnung neben der afd will niemand
sitzen der bisherige nachbar fdp möchte
in die mitte rücken neben rot und grün
die union müsste dann aber weiter nach
rechts und wehrt sich
wir haben unseren platz hier möchten wir
also auch entsprechend gerne behalten
weil wir auch in der mitte des
politischen spektrums stehen als breit
aufgestellte volkspartei viele
baustellen für den neuen bundestag
morgen ab 11 uhr kommt er dann erstmals
zusammen
aus der korona krise ist eine knapp
heitz krise geworden so fasst ein
volkswirt heute die lage der deutschen
wirtschaft zusammen wegen
lieferengpässen an allen ecken und enden
ist der geschäftsklimaindex des ifo
instituts zum vierten mal in folge
gefallen in ihm bewerten die unternehmen
ihre derzeitige geschäftslage und die
erwartungen für das kommende halbe jahr
laut ifo bekommt zunehmend auch der
einzelhandel die probleme zu spüren und
auch die belastungen durch die korona
krise werden nicht so schnell
verschwinden denn die vierte welle nimmt
weiter fahrt auf die sieben tage
incidents steigt seit tagen deutlich an
auf jetzt bundesweit
110,1 die pandemie bleibt auch weltweit
ein problem vor allem in den ärmeren
ländern das ist ein wichtiges thema beim
weltgesundheitsgipfel in berlin britta
spiekermann
zweiter tag des weltgesundheitsgipfel
sin berlin zentrale themen globale
zusammenarbeit während einer pandemie
und impft gerechtigkeit
wir haben alle mittel die wir brauchen
funktionierende
gesundheitssysteme und medizinischer
versorgung aber die welt hat diese
mittel nicht gut genutzt
sein appell länder müssten beim
impfstoff zugunsten bedürftiger
zurücktreten
hierzulande ist ausreichend impfstoff
vorhanden doch die impf zahlen
stagnieren die skepsis ist weiterhin
groß große wellen schlägt nach wie vor
der impfstatus des
fußball-nationalspielers joshua kimmig
er hatte erklärt er habe persönlich noch
ein paar bedenken gerade was fehlende
langzeitstudien angehe diese begründung
ist aus sicht des paul-ehrlich-instituts
zuständig für arzneimittelsicherheit
wissenschaftlich unhaltbar langzeit
nebenwirkungen dies nach jahren
auftreten sind bei impfstoffen generell
nicht bekannt in den ersten drei
oktoberwochen waren von rund 1000
intensivpatienten rund 200 fälle
vollständig geimpft besonders
betroffenen menschen über 60 laut
bundesweitem register sind die
intensivstationen noch moderat belegt
die situation könnte sich aber aus einem
grund verschärfen wir wissen aus unseren
aktuellen umfragen und erhebungen dass
20 bis 30 prozent der deutschen betten
gar nicht betreibbar sind der deutschen
der sich betten aufgrund von mangel an
pflegepersonal und das verkompliziert
die situation für die herbst und für den
winter die epidemische lage könnte ende
november auslaufen wenn der bundestag so
entscheidet der
bundesgesundheitsminister empfiehlt dies
aus den ländern kommt jedoch protest
in vielen ländern osteuropas steigen die
korona infektionen derzeit sprunghaft an
auch bei unseren nachbarn in polen die
behörden melden rund 3000 neuinfektionen
binnen 24 stunden fast doppelt so viele
wie vor einer woche in polen liegt die
impfquote deutlich unter eu schnitt
bisher es nur die hälfte der bevölkerung
geimpft limmer kers dann berichtet er
dagegen eine corona impfung 57 jahre alt
dann wurde er krank ist seit mehr als
drei wochen schon in der klinik
wenn man hier sieht wie die menschen
sterben
das bringt einen zum nachdenken
[Musik]
zenon ist nur ein beispiel denn immer
mehr kurven patienten werden in polens
krankenhäuser eingeliefert die meisten
jungen ungeimpft auch die zahl derer die
beatmet werden müssen nimmt zu
die menschen die bei uns landen und in
der lage sind sich mitzuteilen bitten
uns um die impfung als ob die impfung
eine medizin wäre ihren zustand
verbessern würde
dabei kann sich jeder impfen bevor es zu
spät ist doch viele wollen nicht dieses
impfzentrum im südosten polens ist die
meiste zeit leer nur etwa 120 menschen
kommen pro woche
je ländlicher desto geringer ist auf die
impfbereitschaft in die avantgarde laska
im osten des landes gibt es relativ
gesehen die meisten corona fälle in der
stadt sind noch knapp 50 prozent doppelt
geimpft im landkreis nur etwa ein
drittel
es gibt gerüchte dass die impfstoffe
unwirksam sind ich bin nicht geimpft und
ich werde es auch nicht tun
ich gehöre nicht zu denen die verstehen
warum sich menschen nicht impfen lassen
sie schaden nur sich selbst
polens regierung hat fürs impfen
geworben doch damit viele nicht erreicht
nun füllen sich die intensivstationen
wieder und die neuinfektionen steigen
weiter dramatisch woche für woche
in einem zdf- heute live geht es gleich
auch um nebenwirkungen der korona
impfung zu gast ist ein mitglied der
ständigen impfkommission sie können
fragen stellen um 19 uhr 30 in der zdf-
heute- app und auf unseren social media
kanälen in die türkei die ankündigung
von präsident erdogan 10 westliche
botschafter zur unerwünschten person
erklären zu lassen hatte einen
diplomatischen eklat ausgelöst nach
signalen der annäherung aus den usa nun
der rückzieher von erdogan die
diplomaten werden wohl nicht ausgewiesen
die botschafter hatten sich für einen
inhaftierten menschenrechtler eingesetzt
aus istanbul jörg brase
am morgen noch herrschte alarmstimmung
der wechselkurs der lehrer brach
zunächst noch weiter ein bei vielen
herrscht angst dass der botschafter
streit folgen haben könnte vor wenigen
minuten ging präsident erdogan vor die
presse sendete zeichen der entspannung
unsere absicht war es nie eine krise
heraufzubeschwören unser ziel war es das
recht die ehre und die souveränität
unserer nation zu schützen und wir sehen
das heute dieselben botschafter eine
neue erklärung abgegeben haben in der
sie gegenüber unserem rechtsstaat und
unserer nation das unrecht das sie uns
angetan haben zurückgenommen haben
gemeint ist dieser tweet der
us-botschaft in der türkei man halte
sich an die wiener konvention heißt es
da die verbietet diplomaten sich in
innere angelegenheiten des gastlandes
einzumischen für beobachter der versuch
den gefährlichen streit zu entschärfen
ich denke man wird versuchen die ganze
sache im sande verlaufen zu lassen man
wird versuchen wieder andere themen in
den mittelpunkt zu rücken am ende war
das ganze nichts weiter als ein blog die
drohungen erdogan den deutschen
botschafter jürgen schulz und neun
seiner westlichen kollegen auszuweisen
war eine reaktion auf deren offenen
brief darin forderten sie das urteil des
europäischen menschenrechtsgerichtshofes
umzusetzen den inhaftierten kultur mit
zehn osman kavala freizulassen verärgern
eine einmischung in innere
angelegenheiten der türkei nach den
lauten worten erdogan vom wochenende
erklärte er nun die botschafter würden
in zukunft sicher vorsichtiger sein von
einer ausweisung ist nun keine rede
der erste deutsche prozess gegen eine
igs rückkehrerin ging mit einer hohen
haftstrafe zu ende zehn jahre gefängnis
für die 30 jährige jennifer bay aus
niedersachsen sie soll unter anderem
mitverantwortlich sein für den
qualvollen tod eines fünfjährigen
zusammen mit ihrem mann hatte sie das
hier sie tische mädchen im irak als
sklavin gehalten petra neubauer
auch heute verbirgt jennifer wie ihr
gesicht sorgfältig vor den kameras die
frau die an 77 verhandlungstagen stets
in sich gekehrt wirkte bringt bei der
urteilsverkündung sichtlich um fassung
die angeklagte unter anderem will einem
verbrechen gegen die menschlichkeit mit
todesfolge in der form der versklavung
und wegen mitgliedschaft licher
betätigung in einer terroristischen
vereinigung zu einer
gesamtfreiheitsstrafe von zehn jahren
verurteilt
laut gericht haben die deutsche und ihr
irakische ehemann als anhänger des eine
jüdische frau und deren fünfjährige
tochter in falludscha als sklaven
gehalten
tatenlos jennifer w zu wie ihr mann das
mädchen zur strafe in der hitze fesselte
und es starb die bundesanwaltschaft
hatte dafür eigentlich lebenslang
gefordert aber die angeklagte wurde
schuldig gesprochen für den tod eines
kindes in einem fernen bürgerkriegsland
vor vielen jahren und das ist für mich
das entscheidende
die richter begründeten das strafmaß
damit dass die verantwortung der
angeklagten minder schwer gewesen sei
die verteidigung zufrieden und zwar
wichtig die subjektive schulte anklagen
herauszuarbeiten und sie nicht für das
verantwortlich zu machen was der es
insgesamt den jesiden zweifelsohne
angetan hat die mutter des toten
mädchens gezeichnet von gewalt und leid
trat als nebenklägerin auf für sie ist
es zumindest etwas genugtuung dass mit
der verurteilung von jennifer wie heute
der tod ihrer kleinen tochter nicht
ungesühnt bleibt
nach afrika in den sudan der heute von
einem putsch erschüttert wurde schon
wieder erst im april 2009 10 hatte das
militär nach massenprotesten die
30-jährige herrschaft des autoritären
machthaber omar al-baschir beendet eine
übergangsregierung aus militärischen und
zivilen kräften sollte das land im
nordosten afrikas neu aufbauen doch nun
übernahm die armee in khartum die
kontrolle der ministerpräsident wurde
offenbar festgesetzt anna wassberg
berichtet
die stimmung ist aufgeheizt zehntausende
demonstranten sind auf den straßen im
sudan das volk ist stärker rufen sie und
protestieren damit gegen eine
militärregierung
was das militär gerade tut ist ein
verrat an allen zivilpersonen an allen
fronten es ist unsere pflicht etwas zu
bewegen die straßen zu blockieren und zu
verhindern dass es irgendeine
militärregierung formiert
fast 30 jahre lang regierte hier omar
al-baschir 2009 10 wurde er aus dem amt
getrieben nach massenprotesten und
militärputsch seitdem übergangsregierung
aus militär und zivilisten ohne wenig
fortschritt im land jetzt hat das
militär den ausnahmezustand ausgerufen
und verkündet die übergangsregierung sei
aufgelöst
ab heute bis zu den parlamentswahlen
2023 werden wir uns kümmern um die
renten der menschen sicherheit bieten
und ein geeignetes und friedliches
umfeld schaffen für politische parteien
wo damit wahlen wie geplant stattfinden
können
das internet wurde abgeschaltet der
flughafen geschlossen
ministerpräsident abdullah hampp soll
von angehörigen des militärs verschleppt
worden sein an einen unbekannten ort die
lage im sudan ist im moment vor allem
unübersichtlich das auswärtige amt sagt
deshalb wer gerade im sudan ist solle
sich möglichst schnell an einen sicheren
ort begeben und menschenansammlungen
vermeiden
der zweite putsch in nicht mal drei
jahren und die sudanesen fordern endlich
demokratische reformen in diesen krisen
gebeutelten land
jetzt sind wir beim sport norbert
englischer fußball da konnte jürgen
klopp einen spektakulären sieg der fc
liverpool hat im spitzenspiel gestern
abend manchester united mit 500 geradezu
gedemütigt das ist die höchste
heimniederlage die der englische
rekordmeister bislang gegen die reds
kassiert hat
herausragend musallam mit drei treffern
sein lachen wurde immer breiter als der
ägypter bereits in der ersten halbzeit
das 3 zu 0 schoss und
in der nachspielzeit sogar noch
nachlegte gegen manchester united sala
derzeit der weltbeste spieler er ist in
großartiger form und mit dem ganzen
rummel souverän
nach zuckerpass von henderson gelingt
sala ein kunststück aus vollem lauf das
15 0 mit zauberhafter leichtigkeit
immer geschichte schreiben mit diesem
team und das handy ausgemacht es
war der höchste sieg in manchester in
fast 100 jahren
gestern drei sonntagsspiele in der
fußball-bundesliga köln und leverkusen
trennten sich ebenso wie stuttgart und
union unentschieden und bochum holte den
zweiten sieg in serie nach der frühen
vfl führung ging frankfurt dann die
entscheidung kurz vor spielende
sebastian polter zum 2 0 endstand bochum
jetzt tabellenvierzehnter einen platz
vor der eintracht
und alle tore von allen spielen des
neuen spieltag können sie sich noch mal
ganz eng wobei uns anschauen wie immer
online zusammengefasst auf zdf heute.de
und in der zdf- heute so bleiben sie
immer am ball
gestern hatte sich der vfl wolfsburg von
chefcoach mark van bommel getrennt heute
hat dessen assistent michael frontzeck
vorübergehend das training beim
bundesligisten übernommen zur formel 1
und zum spannenden wm zweikampf zwischen
titelverteidiger lewis hamilton und max
förster der niederländer der gewann
gestern den großen preis der usa und
siegte in seinem red bull mit nur 1,3
sekunden vorsprung vor lewis hamilton im
mercedes auf platz drei landete sergio
perez sebastian vettel wurde zehnter
verstappen führt jetzt die weltrangliste
mit zwölf punkten vorsprung an bei noch
fünf ausstehenden
das war's vom sport dankeschön ein
dicker abschiedskuss von mama direkt vor
dem schultor viele jugendliche würden
das heutzutage als kritisch bezeichnen
hochnotpeinlich und zum fremdschämen
wünscht das ist das jugendwort des
jahres bedeutet so was wie
zusammengezuckt gewählt hat das
kunstwort übrigens keine peinliche
erwachsenen jury sondern jugendliche
selbst haben abgestimmt
das wetter bleibt ruhig und herbstlich
details hat gleich aus dem verlies das
heute journal mit bettina schausten um
viertel nach zehn danke für ihr
interesse einen schönen abend noch und
bis morgen wenn sie möchten auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]
ein kunde und herzlich willkommen zum
wetter eine hochdruckbrücke hat sich
ausgebildet und die reicht von osteuropa
über mitteleuropa bis raus auf den
atlantik und hält allerdings ein tief
über süditalien fest immer wenn tiefs
festhängen bedeutet das dass es extrem
wetter gibt und dass hier wird bis
freitag 300 bis 400 liter in süditalien
an regen abladen ansonsten überquert uns
eine kaltfront einmal ostwärts und die
bringt in der kommenden nacht schon ganz
im westen regen nach norden hin einzelne
gewitter sonst gibt es viele wolken im
süd osten lockert es auf und es bildet
sich nebel dort bis 0 grad also hieß
reifglätte inklusive im nordwesten
werden zehn grad erreicht ja und morgen
tagesverlauf ziehen die wolken weiter in
die mitte voran an der ostsee gibt es
auch blitz und donner nach osten ein
wenig sonnenschein so ähnlich auch im
süden südwesten steigen die temperaturen
bis auf 16 grad sonst werden 10 bis 15
grad erreicht ja und in den nächsten
tagen erinnert sich wenig nach nebel
sonnenschein ja und wenn der nebel sich
nicht auflöst bleibt es leider dicht und
das bei temperaturen von 9 bis 18 grad
ein schöner abend